- [both] Hi! We're half of the Try Guys.
- Ned and Zach are gone.
- They're not dead.
- They're just not here.
They're with their families
for the holiday weekend.
So Eugene and I thought,
"Hey, we got some days,
let's go to the Anime Expo
"and just see what it's all about!"
- We have an opportunity to explore
all of the great booths and expositions--
- And cafes and shows--
- Yeah, everything. That
revolve around Japanese culture.
- [Keith] Yeah, I assume
we're gonna try on
a bunch of different
outfits and just overall
have a Japanese time.
- You're very white today, Keith.
- I'm white everyday, Eugene.
- That's true.
- [Voiceover] The Try Guys
Try Cosplay, Episode Four:
The Try Guys Try Cosplay Fashion.
- So we are here at the h.NAOTO booth.
Uh, with Brittany.
- You're gonna try on steam today.
- [Keith] Okay, steam.
- [Eugene] Oh!
- Can you make us into
beautiful fashion models?
With your line?
- (speaking Japanese) very sexy.
- [All] Oh!
- You think this'll fit my body?
- You look like a Little
House on the Japanese Prarie.
- Get ready for my body!
(They laugh)
- [Eugene] How do you think he looks?
- [Girl in yellow] Oh,
yeah, definitely sexy.
- I love how you're
constantly raising your arms.
- Yeah, because I'm excited! Yay!
- [Eugene] I'm gonna feel
like an old-fashioned baby.
(Keith cries)
- [Naoto] Sexy Victorian baby.
- (Keith sings) Sexy Victorian baby.
- Naoto-san says you're
a sexy Victorian baby.
- I've never had pants, like,
this close to my nipples.
Oh my God, I look beautiful!
- [Naoto] Beautiful.
- [Eugene] Sexy hungry baby!
- We gotta make Eugene look good somehow.
What could you possibly dress him in
that will make him look
even remotely approachable?
It's happening. Eugene's
taking his clothes off!
Nobody faint.
- [Brittany] Suck it in!
- I'm sucking.
- [Brittany] Suck harder.
- (laughing) Suck harder, Eugene.
- We tried; I'm too fat.
- Looks like you're not the sexiest baby.
- I'm like the dark, sexy version of you.
- Yeah. I'd say that's true
just without the clothes.
Oh, look at the tiny hat!
- It's like a little yarmulke.
- Yeah, Judaism is huge in Japan.
Aw, hell yeah!
We look like we're getting married.
I'm a baby waifu.
(Brittany laughs)
- Husbando--
- Baby husbando.
- No, baby waifu.
- You can't marry a baby
if you're not a baby.
That's just not okay.
- No, I could still marry a baby.
- How do we look? How does he look?
- So cool.
- I feel like I would,
like, haunt people sexily.
- Yeah, he'd be like--
- I'd be like, "Ooooohhhh."
- Especially with my legs.
I must look like a spider.
- I think we're missing one
thing, right, Naoto-san?
- Yeah. Please catwalk! (claps)
- [Eugene] (making techno sounds)
Sexy baby, sexy baby!
(Keith makes drum sounds)
- [Keith] So do you think we could be
your new models, like next year?
- Yes!
- Yeah!
- Of course!
- Thanks so much for letting
us be sexy ghost ladies.
- Thank you.
- Yes, arigato gozaimasu.
Next time you go shopping,
consider h.NAOTO.
Yes, yes, yes. (claps)
Awesome, thank you.
(people cheering)
- Oh my God!
- Oh, me too?
- Tokyo Drift!
We're here at the Maid
And Butler booth? Cafe?
- Cafe.
- Cafe!
- My name is Ally and I am the
Anime Expo Maid And Butler Cafe manager.
It's derived from Japan.
It plays off the otaku fantasy.
And it's this whole roleplaying thing,
so they welcome the guests
and they call them "master" or "mistress".
- [Eugene] Hello, mistress.
- [Keith] Hello, mistress.
So what else is entailed?
Do I need to be sexy?
- I mean, like a very mild,
mild, mild version. But I mean--
- So, like, kiss on the neck.
- No!
- No, no, we're not touching.
So basically, we just, we
need to dress like maids and--
- Kawaii.
- Look real kawaii, and talk to strangers.
- Give 'em a lil kiss on the neck.
- No, we don't kiss them.
(making techno sounds) Anime Expo 2015.
Oh, I already know this is
gonna be so frickin' cute.
- Look at these perky little nipples!
(Ally laughs)
You guys said kawaii wasn't sexy!
Look at these nipples.
- So what is it with Japan
and dressing up like servants for fun?
- Yes, master. What game shall we play?
Come over here, lemme kiss dat neck.
- (laughing) No, you can't do--
- Why can't I kiss their neck?
- [Ally] You need a maid name.
- Neck Kisser.
(Ally laughs)
- How do you say kiss in Japan?
- Yeah, "chu".
- Keithchu? That sounds like Pikachu.
- Yeah, why not?
- Pikachu never made out
with anybody on Pokemon.
- [Eugene] So basically
his name is "Keith-kiss".
Alright, so now it's time
to turn me into a butler.
- Yes.
- Luckily today I wore a full suit.
- Yeah.
- Against the wishes of my
entire production crew and Keith.
- It's like 90 degrees out.
- [Eugene] This guy.
Whatever, I knew in the back of my heart--
- The back of your heart?
(Ally laughs)
Who says that?
The back of your heart?!
- We're at Anime Expo; everything goes.
I don't know what a heart is.
So basically I just have to
throw on this vest and tie?
- Yeah.
- So Eugene doesn't have
to get naked for his?
- I'm totally in character...genetically.
Can I just be called Tokyo Drift?
- The one thing about being a butler
that you have to remember is
you have to be a gentleman.
- Use the back of your heart for that one.
- (laughing) Yeah.
- Shut up.
- Hello. Hello, mistress.
- So now we talk to people?
- Yeah!
- How are you?
- [Girl in ponytail] Good.
- Yes. What's up?
- You both look very beautiful today.
- [Ally] There we go!
- [Eugene] You took a girl's cookie.
As a maid you should
be serving the cookies,
not eating the cookies.
- [Keith] I thought it was a free cookie!
- It was not a free cookie.
- I want a croissant!
- That is why we have no one to talk to.
- Please sit down.
Oh my gosh, this is so exciting!
Oh my gosh! Hahahahaha!
- Welcome to our table, mistresses.
- Yes, mistresses, hahahahaha!
Everyone get some glass.
- This is my maid friend Keithchu.
- And this is my butler
friend Tokyo Drift.
What fun we're having with glass.
- You guys also do sometimes
a little dance as well, right?
- We do! We put on a really good show.
(slow jam pop music)
- I hope I don't fall in love!
(crowd laughs)
- Too late!
- [Eugene] So, Ally-san, that was amazing.
- Thank you!
- I didn't know we were
gonna get serenaded.
- Yeah. It totally
happens only here at A-Ex.
- [Keith] I got danced upon.
- [Ally] Yes, you did.
- And you did not kiss anyone's neck.
- [Keith] I did steal a cookie.
- [Ally] Oh, that's okay.
- So for the Butler And Maid Cafe--
- [Whole group] Itterasshai-mase!
- Yay!
- [Voiceover] And with
that, our heroes' adventures
in the world of cosplay
have come to an end.
Having gained a respect and understanding
of the fandom, the guys who try
will now focus their targets elsewhere.
But the question still remains:
what will they try next?
(toast screams)
Oh, ha! You've gotten me again, toast.